it's all aboveboard there's no one
Travis or anything an officer pulls you
over at a checkpoint what's he looking
for
the kidnapper an escaped convict how
about an unbuckled seatbelt oh uh no
seatbelt today huh you know what that
means it's that time of year again click
it or ticket it Ron
you know helps you remember things you
know when cops stand out across the
nation to save you not from bad guys but
from yourself it's for your good and
they're paying special attention to men
aged 18 to 34 so the laws wear seatbelts
except for you right you're special and
fellas don't try pulling a seat belt
fake-out remember this cops have been
trained to spot seat belt violations
even if and they don't give out fake
tickets Maryland state troopers have
used night vision gear to ticket
motorists New Jersey might fine or jail
you if your pooch isn't strapped in and
in Minnesota police have gone old-school
spying on drivers from a school bus and
then tipping off one of several
undercover cops who are along for the
ride we were surprised at the number of
seat belt violations and mature adults
to 30s 50s 60s and 185 year old woman
you know it seems like cops are going
through an awful lot of trouble trying
to protect us from ourselves I'm no hero
maybe a little bit of a hero but
remember has absolutely nothing to do
with racing revenue it's all aboveboard
there's no one Travis or anything you
filming me you filming it pop but come
on Hill cops have better things to do
86% of Americans already do buckle up so
why bother with all the tough talking
PSAs checkpoints and sneaky school buses
especially in the nation where a
majority of violent crimes go unsolved
so forget about trying to get everybody
to use a seatbelt all the time and go
catch some more murders and racist one
two three four the show on Twitter
submit your nominees for next month and
check out Christopher Meg's this month's
featured follower is the big shot with
Twitter in me are you twittering me
you